all right today's topic we got the
twinners twit was it tinder twitter this
one this one we had the tinder swindler
this is the twitter swindler so this all
started on valentine's day when belly
what'd you say
what
when when is that on valentine's day
okay when belly
rolling
tweets a mirror selfie of him with
another woman whose uh handle is sativa
monet okay well
who's belly
some some some dude some do right he
does music apparently right not the
belly from toronto no no shout out to
him he's actually from ottawa he's
remodeling from ottawa i know there's
stuff
he's from ottawa tomorrow yeah shout out
to him
and he's a great producer
no don't mess with the hair
come on baby
come on baby let's find the bottom we
sipping dumb period oh my date that
[ __ ] i hated loving these people
just like that
i hated lebanese
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
and everybody was singing it all the
girls were singing if you thought
lebanese people were arrogant wait till
masari came out that [ __ ] changed the
game shout out to belly [ __ ] my sorry
let's keep going
no no no no no no no no belly rolling he
tweets himself with a woman all right
and her followers are like yo what's
going on you guys together
and that's when her story begins and so
she says look she met belly on twitter
and they click well he flew
out to meet her in april 2021 okay they
planned their following hangouts she
planned to buy her flights out to meet
him and he would organize the rest first
time they were supposed to meet his
cousin supposedly died so they
reschedule okay
which is fine you know
cousins dies
i appreciate you they're moving the
funeral to saturday that's the only days
that can get
prison furlough she basically says
something very supportive he says i want
you there at the same time i know my
family needs me especially my auntie
this is all bad timing honestly i don't
want to leave you at the hotel while
coming to see me that would be trash for
me okay all right very kind of him i
think i think he's very fantastic that
he's being considerate they rescheduled
for june 2020 and then he had legal
issues apparently his license was
suspended and had to attend a court date
to fight
babe i gotta do four days and pay five
thousand dollars you're coming next
weekend right i'm coming on the 25th oh
my god baby what the [ __ ] that's
ridiculous that you have to do all this
over some traffic [ __ ] well if you
didn't okay it's not that ridiculous but
yeah that's not what we were talking
about i don't mean to judge too harshly
but you guys only went out for one
weekend and y'all call each other babe
and [ __ ] like that i find that [ __ ]
super cringey
am i crazy i can understand why you're
saying that you know what i mean oh yeah
baby
my boo like when people start talking
like that after so quickly i just yeah
so he sends her an image of what he's
got to deal with she was starting to
feel like things were a little
suspicious but kept going they
rescheduled the third time this time he
had ghosted her
and once he replied it seemed to be
another person telling her he had been
hospitalized
due to his sugar spiking because he's
diabetic everything okay here i'm
texting everyone that reached out so
this is like or another person on his
phone juice went to the hospital earlier
today due to his sugar spiking he'll
have his phone tomorrow
she goes please please call me back when
you get your phone back babe someone
sent her a supposed photo of him at the
hospital being unconscious and treated
in reality it was a live photo she could
see that he was moving in the end of the
live photo he was clearly in the er but
he claimed to have been there for days
so why hasn't he been admitted also the
white board on the back shows a wrong
date from the day it was sent
but the promise is a live photo so she's
saying he's unconscious
right so he was taking the phone you
know where the photo is huh you know
what a life photo is yeah it's like a
show it captures like one two seconds
i've seen yeah you see that yeah yeah
yeah so she became suspicious suspicious
at this point apparently he's not a
homeowner like he said he was he lives
in his mother's home with her his
business became inactive and he lost his
website domain due to not paying for it
and he was even he was not even a
successful songwriter like he claimed so
she then blocks him and moves on with
her life she receives an email from him
three months later where he expresses
his apologies and regrets on what
happened offering to pay her back for
the plane ticket i just wanted to reach
out and apologize for my actions i'm not
looking for a response i'm not looking
for sympathy
i only want you to hear me out and
hopefully find it in your heart to
forgive first things first
papa freaks all the honeys but we get
the point basically he's just he's he's
just waxing on poet here right so then
even other artists who he claimed to
have worked with came out like i don't
know this [ __ ] all right so
that's the gist of it okay this guy's
been lying about his whole life lying
about the whole thing trying to get out
of these dates all those other stuff
okay
so
now that we're there
what's the big thing about this why was
it a big bad story
the links to which he lied to get out of
the dates
the life he tried to portray online even
though he was a complete fraud saying i
worked with nas i worked with jay-z and
i was like why is he doing all this
extra stuff to
front online so and then
when he was caught in the lie this is
what killed me someone said oh your
cousin didn't even die he's like no no
it was actually one of my my uncles i
call him cousins and he posted a picture
of the guy turns out the guy that he
said died
he has no relation to whatsoever so even
when he was called down in the lives he
he tripled listen there's yeah
when i was in high school
there's a couple people like that yeah a
couple of people like that because you
know
high schools trying to be different
you know i mean you try to
show that you're different that you're
worth something yeah you don't want to
be you want to be special yeah and you
had all these people lying you had a
couple of people that i know i was lying
like i remember it was a another girl
like
it doesn't matter her name but she was
always talking about yeah i go to new
york often and i chill with this and
that and all the big stars big lies big
lies like why are you lying because
people wanna they just wanna
show that they're special it's a
pathology
it becomes that there's some people that
do not get out of this cycle that they
were in high school i got some of my
friends their best days
were in high school the minute they got
out of high school being an adult sucked
still to this day sucks because they
have all these responsibilities and
you're not where you're at or what you
want to be and stuff like that so
whenever i talk to them they always talk
about
they always talk about just just high
school high school and stuff like that
so the same way these people are talking
about high school there's some people
that lie
that
lies just like the same pattern that
they had in high school but they keep on
doing that because that's all they have
people don't know better people will
believe what you tell them you know if
you're from out of town i could tell you
that i'm a big monstrous producer ah me
in quebec
i'm a big actor
yeah i do voices i do this and that i'm
big i'm no no
you know i could amplify what the you
know yeah so and they just do that just
to make them feel special they are
failures in life so they build the life
that they would want to have and they
roll with that but then at some point
keep on lying they can't back it up so
all the thing it all comes up combos
down fake it till you make it right fake
it till you make it but you never made
it i think to fake it to them you make
it thing is good when you actually
eventually gonna make like
okay let's just work towards that but it
doesn't work toward winking it let's
just start with the first thing okay
let's go
first let's start working first first
sometimes they posted a picture with a
girl that you were no longer seeing that
has got to be one of the [ __ ] lamest
moves i've ever had that's fuckboy that
that is
that's like the epitome of being a loser
that's fuckboy a girl you're not [ __ ]
with you post a picture with her on
valentine's day [ __ ] you lame memories
you know what i mean but how okay okay
it's it you're a hundred percent that's
crazy that's crazy like if i girl i
messed with before post a picture of me
and her on valentine's day yeah i'm like
[ __ ] you bugging what's wrong with
you yeah yeah
i'm trying to [ __ ] somebody else
you messing with my game extra weird but
there's people that do that like the
yeah yeah like what they wish they had
like they had that girl and they really
wish they would be here with her they
post them they post her they post a
picture without any explanation so
people they wonder
are we together oh you know i mean yeah
there's so many levels i think you
touched on a really good one which is
just the intention seeking i think
there's so much pressure on like
making it or like seepingly cool like i
know regular ass girls and you look at
their instagram it's so extra like it's
like
like like it's like i'm like i know
you're not living there i know what you
do with like but they they need to
project that right because they get that
adulation right they get that people
like oh the comments and it feels good
if we're keeping it a stack when you get
all those likes and you get those
comments people do get a good feedback a
good rush
then you become almost a slave to that
rush you're constantly looking for the
next way to flex right the newest angle
that you can take the newest location
you can take your instagram photos and
it becomes a perpetual cycle and then at
some point you start being like these ig
models who'll be out here going on a set
and then pretending they're in a jet
right it's the same thing it's the same
pathology like you discussed right so i
understand that our society really does
encourage a lot of this fakeness right
and this is just a reflection on we can
care more about image than substance
that's all this is absolutely right we
care more about image and substance
because
what he was doing worked for him
for what he wanted
right he wanted the ladies well she fell
for right she heard she was a successful
songwriter she was into all that stuff
right she was into it and they did smash
so it worked so you got you got to smash
with that right that's the [ __ ] up
thing
and so it is a reflection of the times
we live in the way we go about stuff the
reason why i talk about
high school like that it reminds me of a
story that happened to me in high school
where i have a cousin right yo he's
older than me
we do motorcycles together and
everything and stuff and
like who was older than me i was he was
training
he was running track and field was
running
with one of the best runners in canada
anyways gold medalist and stuff like
that he was doing that so to me when i
was a kid i was looking up to him right
and on top of that this [ __ ]
looks good so this is my cousin right
i'm in high school and in high school i
am not
popular
at all
i don't know i'm not popular all right
yeah like i'm like
walter weeks in his when he was in
barbados
all that to say
i'm there i'm not popular and then i see
my one day i go to school and i see my
cousin he's in the gym
and he used to go to my high school
actually the reason why i went to high
school is because moccasin went to the
high school
now i'm in sect 3
not being popular i see my cousin there
i'm like yo
what are you doing here it's like oh i
study to be a gym teacher
i study to be a gym teacher uh i'm gonna
be a montage
that's like my
yeah that's what i do oh dawg
so excited
i go to class because i have to go it
was in the morning i go to class
and then all the girls they talk about
my cousin they're like oh [ __ ]
did you see the new stash yeah
the new dude yo this [ __ ] looks
fine i'm in the back of the class like
this oh yeah [ __ ]
you think he fine all right
um
what are you guys guys talking about
other news stats here who the new guy
you know the new stash here oh my cousin
he's your cousin
instantly
i had attention on me
just because i was related to that just
because i was next to the mother yeah
that's my cousin first it was like no
that's not a that's not that's not your
cousin it's good because it sort of
happened that that that same day we had
a gym class so [ __ ] i walk in
the gym class fashionably yeah you
didn't walk in feet first head first you
went in dick first fashionably late yeah
you were just leaning i was no i was
waiting for people to be all sitting
down and then i got out of the of the
locker room you know and what i did is i
went to the locker room and i went to
him first hey what up
you good cousin yeah i'm good cousin
familia i'm just because i was next to
that but you see i could have latched on
to that damn right and kept on dying and
stuff in it no i'm good you should have
they'd be like yo is that really your
cousin who what what i'm in the streets
with my family
but that's what i'm saying
what mother like people do so you just
see that relation
once you get that feeling
now you're ready to lie for it but some
people they lie every day yo yeah i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go to new york so my
cousin and we're gonna chill with jay-z
i got people like that in high school
you know who the [ __ ] you are yeah yeah
we get that man
so i think there's like a there's an
unfortunate need it's like here's a
weird thing right he went to such great
lengths to lie about that and do all
that stuff
on a more minor scale okay if we scale
it down obviously the deceit he went to
was far over extreme right
folks are doing it every day on social
media to a lesser degree posing behind
beside cars they don't own right even
though they're not saying it's my car
they're really leaching off of that that
feel right
using filters or stuff that completely
change their faces or whatever it is
right angles to mr we're all trying to
project an image to the world
and some people take it as far as this
person i am of the mindset that i think
until the values that people inherit
change until this need to always appear
amazing changes
this kind of stuff will never stop
because there's too many benefits to
lying into being deceitful
yeah me like that that's the first thing
the second thing about this story that i
thought was was wild is a lot of the
lies were just unnecessary
you didn't want to see her again just
say listen i'm not feeling it move on
we are so afraid of confrontation we're
so desperate to try to maintain our
image we'll tell unnecessary lies
because we think it might hamper it a
little bit
bruh the lies made the whole story worse
if you were to just something to the
first time and then the second time she
came out you're like i'm not down this
would have never happened your image
would have barely changed but because
you were worried about how she would
perceive you
but man [ __ ] this guy you wanted to be
the perfect dude to her someone you
don't even care to see again
you want to be the perfect dude to her
you told the most unnecessary lies and
people do this all the time
they do this all the time for no reason
in a dating context we call that white
lies but then after that there's a
dating contest what do you just bruh
just say you don't want to see them
again sometimes the girls be like yo
i don't see us going anywhere
yeah she's hurt yeah i don't feel the
best but she knows where i stand and i
haven't had to lie and that happens
sometimes it doesn't mean they're gonna
like you right it doesn't mean that
you're gonna have the best outcome in
terms of
how they perceive you but
you told the truth now you can move on
and honestly it's just so much easier
what because i want her to leave but
still like me yeah
eve
you leave yeah but please like me yeah
that's crazy
it's like you still
you're not gonna be connected with that
[ __ ] no so
harass no
don't make it too long just
high one oh that's my favorite one bro
that's good yeah every time i see a
little kid running around screaming like
one
father
how does that one yeah
you thought it was just like south
africa yeah yeah yeah
that's a word that's actually not a word
but they do that yeah
anyways i digress
that's a sidebar okay i always want to
talk about this story a little bit it
made me chuckle
as far as this guy goes man whatever
there's a lot of them out there isn't he
just the male version of a city girl
what are they called city boys yeah
right because
what do the city girls talk about
finessing dudes yeah ain't this the
other end of that spectrum yes
there's a bunch of finesses out there
you know mrs monet you got finessed not
super well because he got caught but hey
it is what it is it's still finesse i
know that he got he got what he wanted
we're not endorsing it but yeah
at some points we can't let city girls
run up the score all the time yeah
sometimes you gotta get it yeah it's the
fourth quarter we're losing but
let's score a touchdown or two you know
what i mean have some [ __ ] pride get
our [ __ ] boys in there
that's right it's like [ __ ] boys that
email that he wrote was the most fuckboy
email listen
listen i don't even need to reply and
maybe you don't deserve my apology you
know what this dude's doing right there
can we tell you reverse psychology
ish but you know what he's really done
he's trying to [ __ ] you oh
yeah we call that a hook i [ __ ] up for
three months i made you pay for the
tickets i did all this stuff but let me
see
if i could [ __ ] again
hey girl
and you know what shout out to her
because one thing she did that i really
liked is they're like yo why would you
even get with this guy he looks like a
loser she's like i'm not going in front
his dick game was a basic if you
could be honest if you got
something possible
oh no she said no listen i wouldn't do
all this for dick trash yeah yeah yeah
yeah
okay
all right
you see what he did there what i do he
was trying to [ __ ]
miss monday
go gone
anyways i'm not in the streets let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below do you guys agree or just really
want to hear from you
you're not